This next video is on inferring.
I like to think
of these tasks where
the model takes a text as input and
performs some kind of analysis.
So this could be extracting labels,
extracting names,
kind of understanding the
sentiment of a text,
that kind of thing.
So if you want to extract a sentiment,
positive or negative,
of a piece of text,
in the traditional
machine learning workflow, you'd
have to collect the label data set, train
a model, figure out how to deploy
the model somewhere in
the cloud and make inferences. And
that could work pretty well, but
it was, you know, just
a lot of work to
go through that process. And
also for every task, such
as sentiment versus
extracting names versus
something else, you
have to train and
deploy a separate model. One
of the really nice
things about large language
model is that for
many tasks like these, you
can just write a
prompt and have it
start generating results pretty
much right away. And
that gives tremendous speed in terms
of application development. And
you can also just use one model, one
API to do many
different tasks rather than
needing to figure out
how to train and deploy a lot of
different models. And
so with that, let's jump
into the code to see how you can
take advantage of this. So here's
our usual starter code. I'll just run
that.
And the most fitting example I'm
going to use is a review for a lamp. So,
"Needed a nice lamp for
the bedroom and this
one had additional storage" and
so on.
So, let me write a prompt
to classify the sentiment of this.
And if I want the system to tell me,
you know, what is the sentiment.
I can just write,
"What is the sentiment
of the following product review"
with the usual delimiter
and the review text and so on and
let's run that.
And this says,
"The sentiment of the
product review is positive.",
which is actually,
seems pretty right. This lamp isn't
perfect, but
this customer seems pretty happy. Seems
to be a great
company that cares about
the customers and products. I
think positive sentiment seems to
be the right answer. Now
this prints out the entire sentence,
"The sentiment of the product
review is positive."
If you wanted to give
a more concise response to
make it easier for post-processing, I
can take this prompt
and add another instruction
to give you answers
to a single word, either
positive or negative. So
it just prints out
positive like this, which
makes it easier for
a piece of text to take this output
and process it and
do something with it.
Let's look at another prompt, again
still using the lamp review.
Here, I have ,it "Identify a list
of emotions that the writer of
the following review is expressing.
Include no more than
five items in this list."
So, large language models are
pretty good at extracting
specific things out of
a piece of text. In this case, we're
expressing the emotions and this could
be useful for
understanding how your
customers think about
a particular product. For
a lot of customer support organizations,
it's important to understand if
a particular user is extremely upset.
So, you might have a different
classification problem like
this, "Is the
writer of the following
review expressing anger?". Because
if
someone is really angry, it might
merit paying extra
attention to have a customer review,
to have customer support or
customer success, reach out
to figure what's going on
and make things right for
the customer. In this case,
the customer is
not angry. And notice that
with supervised learning,
if I had
wanted to build all of
these classifiers, there's no way
I would have been able
to do this with
supervised learning in the
just a few minutes
that you saw me do so in this
video. I'd encourage you to pause
this video and try
changing some of these
prompts. Maybe ask if the customer
is expressing delight or ask if
there are any missing parts and
see if you can a prompt
to make different inferences about this
lamp review.
Let me show some
more things that you
can do with this system,
specifically extracting
richer information from a
customer review.
So, information extraction is
the part of NLP,
of Natural Language Processing,
that relates to taking
a piece of text
and extracting certain things
that you want to know from the text.
So in this prompt, I'm
asking it to identify
the following items, the
item purchase, and
the name of the company
that made the item. Again, if
you are trying to
summarize many reviews from
an online shopping e-commerce website,
it might be useful for your
large collection of reviews
to figure out what
were the items, who made
the item, figure out
positive and negative
sentiment, to track
trends about positive or negative sentiment
for specific items
or for specific
manufacturers. And in
this example, I'm going to
ask it to format your response as a
JSON object with "Item" and "Brand" as
the keys. And so if
I do that, it says the
item is a lamp, the brand is
Lumina, and you can easily load this
into the Python dictionary to then
do additional processing
on this output.
In the examples we've gone through, you
saw how to
write a prompt to recognize
the sentiment, figure out if someone
is angry, and then also extract
the item and the
brand.
One way to extract
all of this information
would be to use
three or four prompts and call "get_completion",
you know, three
times or four times
to extract these different
views one at a time. But
it turns out you
can actually write a
single prompt to extract
all of this information
at the same time. So
let's say "identify the
following items, extract sentiment,
is the
reviewer expressing anger, item purchased,
company that
made it". And then
here I'm also going
to tell it to format
the anger value as a
boolean value, and let me
run that. And this outputs
a JSON where sentiment
is positive, anger, and then
no quotes around false because
it asked it to
just output it as a boolean value. Extracted
the item as "lamp with additional
storage" instead of lamp,
seems okay.
But this way you
can extract multiple fields
out of a piece of text with just
a single prompt.
And, as usual, please feel free
to pause the video and play
with different variations
on this yourself.
Or maybe even try
typing in a totally
different review to see
if you can still
extract these things accurately.
Now, one of the cool applications I've
seen of large language
models is inferring topics. Given
a long piece of text, you
know, what
is this piece of text about? What
are the topics? Here's a
fictitious newspaper article about
how government workers feel
about the agency they
work for. So, the recent
survey conducted by
government, you know, and so
on. "Results revealed that NASA was
a popular department with a high
satisfaction rating." I am
a fan of NASA, I love
the work they do, but this
is a fictitious article. And so,
given an article like this, we can
ask it, with this prompt, to determine
five topics that are
being discussed in the
following text.
Let's
make each item one or two words long, for
my response, in a comma-separated list.
And so, if we
run that, you know, we get
this article. It's about a
government survey, it's about job satisfaction,
it's about NASA, and so
on. So, overall, I think, pretty nice
extraction of a
list of topics. And,
of course, you can also, you know,
split it so you get
a Python list with the five topics that
this article was about.
And if you have a
collection of articles and extract
topics, you can then also
use a large language
model to help you
index into different topics. So,
let me use a
slightly different topic list. Let's
say that we're a
news website or something, and, you know,
these are
the topics we track. "NASA, local
government, engineering, employee satisfaction,
federal government".
And let's say you
want to figure out, given a news
article, which of these
topics are covered in that
news article.
So, here's a prompt that I can use.
I'm going to say, determine
whether each item in
the final list of topics is a topic
in the text below.
Give your answer as a list
of 0 or 1 for each topic.
And so, great. So,
this is the same story text as before.
So, this thing is a story.
It is about NASA. It's
not about local government. It's not
about engineering. It is
about employee satisfaction, and it
is about federal government. So, with
this, in machine learning, this is
sometimes called a "Zero-Shot Learning Algorithm",
because we didn't
give it any training data that was
labeled, so that's Zero-Shot. And
with just a prompt, it
was able to determine which of these topics
are covered in that news article.
And so, if you want to
generate a
news alert, say, so that process news, and
I really like a lot
of work that NASA does.
So, if you want to build a
system that can take this,
put this information into a dictionary,
and whenever NASA news pops up,
print "ALERT: New NASA story!", they
can use this to very
quickly take any article, figure
out what topics it is
about, and if the topic includes NASA,
have it print out "ALERT: New
NASA story!". Oh, just one
thing. I use this topic dictionary down
here. This prompt that I use up
here isn't very robust. If I wanted a
production system, I
would probably have it output the
answer in JSON format, rather
than as a list, because the
output of the large language
model can be a little bit
inconsistent. So, this is actually a
pretty brittle piece
of code. But if
you want, when you're done
watching this video, feel free to
see if you can figure
out how to modify this prompt, to have
it output JSON instead of a
list like this, and then
have a more robust way to
tell if a particular article is a story
about NASA.
So, that's it for inferring. And
in just a few minutes, you
can build multiple systems for making
inferences about text
that previously just
would have taken days or even
weeks for a skilled machine learning
developer. And so, I
find this very exciting
that both for skilled
machine learning developers, as
well as for people that
are newer to machine learning, you
can now use prompting to very
quickly build and start making inferences
on pretty complicated
natural language processing
tasks like these. In
the next video, we'll continue
to talk about exciting things you
could do with large language models,
and we'll go on
to "Transforming". How can you
take one piece of text and transform it
into a different piece
of text, such as translate
it to a different
language. Let's go on to
the next video.